want to tell assa what's been going on
with us so she can watch her tell me
everything i already love it
so he has this god-awful fungal
infection in his foot
that's been there for about three years
let me see it let me see it no
i don't know
wait hold on a second ago you were
sitting with your feet like this
and now all of a sudden you're it's my
right foot i put out
i don't know the right foot's fine yeah
that's that one's fine okay let me use
this one i don't put this one up come on
it's so tough i don't die right now i
don't showcase this one
so lately in the last six months um
every time that we've ever had sex i've
just it's just been really really itchy
for me like afterwards okay like
discharge it almost like a yeast
infection okay but not a yeast infection
the doctor's like no it's not a yeast
infection because you they can look at
it under the microscope immediately
while you're there okay and the guy was
like no it's not canada which is you
know yeah
so now i'm thinking i look at him when
he just you know i just observe him as
he's you know
sitting on the couch or playing on his
and he's always scratching his feet okay
especially with
the his right hand
and the hand that touches your [ __ ]
right so every time we have sex and he
actually touches me with his right hand
or touches me with any hand at all that
happens but if we only have just
straight on [ __ ] and dick yeah i don't
get like no touching right no
but he is in denial he doesn't think
that he's giving me some type of 100
it's you bobby and i'm not even just
saying that to take calyl aside
like let me tell you something so
i just went to this
holistic doctor
and she tested me it's called muscle
testing it sounds like total hocus pocus
and i wouldn't even believe in it if it
didn't happen to me but i had an
infection on my nipple that lasted for
seven months oh my god and i went
through three rounds of antibiotics i
got an ultrasound like i went to three
different doctors and they
didn't know what it was they were like
we don't know why it's happening
sometimes these things happen haha and i
finally i went to this holistic doctor
for something else
and she was like oh is there anything
else wrong with you and i was like
actually my nipple
um has been infected for seven months
what did it look like it looked like a
white head on my knit one
just one and i would pop it and it would
go away for a day and then come back
and it was like it never grew
it wasn't
it was just always this white head it
looked disgusting but it was small
enough that it didn't show on camera
what if your twin sister like yeah
but like so this holistic doctor she's
like all right we're going to do some
muscle testing so she had me read out
loud this list of all these different
bacterias while she clicked my feet
together
and like i i was just like the whole
time i was like this is [ __ ] like i
can't believe i'm doing this this is
[ __ ]
and then finally like i read one
bacteria name which sounded like
something out of like harry potter what
is it it was like no i don't even it's
like
you would probably know it honestly but
i had no idea what i was saying and she
was like that's it that's the one
hogwarts let's just say it was hogwarts
hogwarts i was like hogwart and she was
like that's it that's the one your body
is telling me that's the one
and then she put all these me i know i
know i don't even believe it either but
it happened to me and then she put all
these magnets on me and left me like
that for 20 minutes
and then
i'm not even [ __ ] kidding you the
next morning it was gone and it never
came back do you think it was
coincidence or do you really think it
was her but now you're dr doom and it
wasn't
because it killed the world i think it
was her and it wasn't the power of
positive thinking because i was thinking
very negatively like so i have to go to
the formula you should go her yeah i'm
going to give you guys your info no
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you i'm not putting magnets on me
for my [ __ ] puppy [ __ ] you know what
it is it's got i have foot fungi
yeah i already know what it is so then
stop touching it and touching your
girlfriend's [ __ ] that's disgusting i
don't touch it i just stick my dick and
i go
like that
with the sound as well yeah
yeah
number one yeah number one thank you
very much for the compliments i
appreciate all those things you said
about how you're working i am how good
of an actor i am and the stand-up
situation i appreciate that number two
yes my fingers
are not attractive i was
not blessed with you know long
and big beds of nails i have tiny
triangle
nails and i bite my nails which makes it
even worse okay this is all true all
they wanted is all all these things are
true all these things are true
absolutely okay but yes if we are
building
a finger and more specifically
fingernail hall of shame
well then right next to my buster will
be your disgusting
can opener
first of all do we even need to talk
about the years the years of glue that
we have ruined whatever whatever cuticle
situation you had going on before yeah
yeah it's been ruined by years of
elmer's glue okay so now but yeah why
would you ever choose that to throw at
me as a stone because i'll tell you why
with your disgusting fingers i'll tell
you why grow them with your my selling
point right isn't
hey i'm [ __ ] good looking and i'm
funny
my selling point is this and this [ __ ]
up thing what i'm saying to you is that
good
good no good shitty yes okay my selling
point is not selling my sexuality on
stage okay that's hardly what i'm doing
up there but i don't know why i should
have brought it up but you're right i do
have i i'm more
what we did on the league seven years of
looking at people's fantasy scores yeah
right so
i mean they would never use your fingers
because you know disgust i mean it's
like damn i bite my nails yeah
if it happens to be a good day like
today's not bad it's pretty good yeah
you'd be like oh okay that's not your
hand
can i tell him yeah yeah yeah i have um
i have um ocd no i have
my left foot is a disaster i have
severe foot fungi
i don't want to laugh but you did first
do you really you really did yes and at
one point was that true oh i had it in
my fingers because i scratched my foot
and it went inside religion he gave me
jock itch essentially
it's tragic it was tragic for me did do
you wear a sock when you guys go to bed
one sock on that foot no but he's not
allowed to touch any part of my body
with his left foot like he knows this
it's a disaster it's a disaster is it
what does it look like it's fine i mean
you're not going to go you're not going
to look at it it's fine
but not great it's not great no it's not
is it like uh daniel d lewis he used to
be one of my left foot yeah it's like
that is it like i mean
at one time my left foot was so bad that
when i was on mad a long time it's been
bad for many years
i showed ike berenholtz
my left foot
and he took three steps back and he made
a noise like uh like that
like it was bad
yeah you could see mold does it does it
smell at all yeah like what does it
smell like
like are we talking breathe no i'm
talking no no i'm talking worse than
brie yeah i'm talking about like i can
attest to this uh yeah yeah something
like that as a dead rodent and you can't
get rid of this no i can't it'll be okay
yeah
okay so i got him a big box of this
medication called luzo and it was really
effective it's got to be called loser
poor guy's got a football guy and he's
gonna use a product called loser
i want some yeah over here
and i put it on it worked and it turns
out he doesn't want it to work because
it's an activity for him to scratch and
peel his foot every day he missed it he
missed his foot i missed it
yeah
that's really like that's therapeutic
that's therapy yeah i love it
i love it have you talked to your
therapist about that i don't have a
therapist okay i don't need one you
don't need one no but i uh this is your
therapy yeah i enjoy peeling it
i enjoy i enjoy scratching and deep
scratches it's yeah when i'm in the spa
that's what my that's my ritual yeah
wait so you go in the spa i go to the
top tier of the steam room right and i
put my foot out there you know
i go late so that's no one around and
when i when it when hot gets it gets
itchier when it's hot
yeah my foot and i just take my finger
and i deep scratch it and it feels so
good
does it get infected and i don't know
i'm not a doctor
have you guys seen this
but we know that it's a thing in fact
it was weird huh it wasn't weird you
just it's my [ __ ] always gets itchy
oh wait you got your fingers
let me i think i know what it is because
there's a pringles in my video no it's
his feet
yeah it is they smell so bad
let me tell you in arizona
because he was wearing these shoes the
costumes and i'm like oh you got the
costumes too they're good right
but he had a different colorway yeah he
had the like the the neon colors
whatever and so he and so we're about to
watch the whaling with my mother you
know the whaling and he takes off his
shoes and then i'm like we're sitting by
the t and i go what's that [ __ ] smell
you know the movie came with the smell
no no it was a whale it was his feet i
know man
it's like deep rotten
like and then we're at walmart
like dr scholl's i try to put it in
there he's like dude i don't need that
dude
it's because he loves his fun
and then i even sprayed it he was
watching something on his ipad
and i he brought a spray and he wasn't
using it so i go can i spray it and he
goes yeah and i just
yeah he sprayed the [ __ ] out yeah i
sprayed he was driving crazy it just
smelled yeah has he always had like
mm-hmm so going back to the thing of the
itch i think it's maybe all right steve
you're not a [ __ ] doctor i know
you know he's a hypocrite yeah it's a
great hypothesis it's a great papa
yeah
and um
stone so i come to i fly into um yeah
yeah
our dad's dying right would you say that
he's getting sick
i wouldn't say dying but you know he's
sick he's stable right now
so let me ask you a question is it
appropriate
when your dad's sick
and you're in their house to look at
your brother and go
bob
can we go to walmart to get pringles
let me ask you something is it
appropriate
um
and then yes enough okay so
why why did you want me to get pringles
well i was so bored no no no you okay i
was bored
you know
girl girlfriend's not around yeah yeah
um i was sick of masturbating
with just uh vaseline
because i was just masturbating with uh
vaseline and i would you know paper
towel yeah
yeah okay and so i looked up on um
youtube or google um
well i looked this up i said i looked up
homemade uh pocket [ __ ]
[Laughter]
arson craft during your yeah
definitely
definite arts and crafts so what i found
out is you could take simple household
supplies
and make a
kind of like a fifi like a just a pocket
tell me how from beginning to end it
works good surprisingly how does it
become a vacuum though i'll show you
we'll break
let me just say this before anything
okay what happened that night well i'll
tell you what okay okay
you go bob
check this out
which you think you're gonna see like
you know a cool soccer footage of
something or
you know i mean or a fail you know
you don't think you're gonna see an
instructional manual on how to make a
[ __ ] homemade pocket [ __ ]
no they do so we saw
and then what did we see
um so what you need is uh two sponges
what kind soft or the scrub part or the
soft ones yeah yeah the cleaning right
yeah the cleaning sponges they sell four
packs at walmart yeah um
rubber bands
and then simple just like plastic uh
like grocery store uh you know like the
bags to stuff it in the pringles
um regular plastic yeah just regular
plastic bags
the most important part oh
latex gloves yeah there we go the vagina
that's the vagina that's your vagina
so what happens is um
well we were at walmart and i we bought
two pringles and what did what was stops
us so far all right okay
this is something that i would never do
on my own
okay yeah it's like a brother it's
something that that's not a brother
that's not bonding even uh
bonding
wouldn't even walk around walmart with
me i had to do it separately yeah yeah
he's like dude just yeah you do you get
everything
i'll meet you i'll get you over here
so he has two um pringles
you know the yeah
what do you call them cups
uh i think i got sour cr the onion yeah
and then just the normal there was like
a new bread yeah yeah the brown salt i
got salt and vinegar
yeah whatever is that maybe
and also um
we it went to waste because we didn't
even eat the perfect no we we actually
walked outside of walmart looked around
and then
and then i just i just dumped him you
guys couldn't wait till he got home no
no
he was afraid his main fear was
like my mom discovering well here okay
so
so what you do is this okay did i say
rubber bands yeah okay you just said
rubber pants
what you do is you take the two sponges
okay
you take the glove
okay so you sandwich the two stumps of
sponges
on the glove
no
no no you the the two sponges are like
this yeah and then the glove goes in the
middle yeah you sandwich it yeah yeah
yeah that's what it [ __ ] says okay so
what's touching your penis has to be the
glove right yes yes because it's and the
inside of the of the sponges the sponge
so the glove opening right you you wrap
it yeah right so you sandwich it but
then you wrap
it around the um the two sponges so it
holds in place
and then outside
um outside the pringles the top of it
and then you just rubber band it so it
stays in place
okay so it kind of like it just uh does
that kind of yeah motion yeah yeah yeah
and then um you have two we had a little
arts and crafts sessions upstairs did
you try it or did you try it mine felt
great you got one too you made one too
you had two butters two vinegar
his broke
mine's mine broke because big dick bobby
no it's not that i did too aggressively
yeah yeah yeah i mean he got mad because
mine i got the pink sponges and he mine
looked more like a real yeah and i got a
green one
he got like a great avatar
you're trying to mimic my [ __ ] yeah
these fungus so yeah yeah and so what
what why what i found through oh we we
we forgot the lotion we bought it we'll
forget the location [ __ ] the lotion okay
all right what i found is that you have
to kind of rubber band
the top that like the top entrance part
yeah really tight because mine busted
open i don't understand how the rubber
band works what do you mean okay if
you're lining it you're lining the
inside of the can with a sponge and then
inside of that is the glove right where
does the rubber band actually go well
this is bob discovered this he modified
also bobby the one that's video no no no
no no the next night the next night he
goes dude i got it
he's like steve dude
you're like you're gross that's what
life's about
and he's like because we had to re
uh redo it yeah so he modified it so
before we even put it in the pringles
can he uh rubber band it all together
yeah um the sponges
um the sponges with the latex glove oh
so it sticks together so it's a tighter
vagina because if you don't put the
rubber band around there then i imagine
it's like your dick will open it up and
it just becomes like that's it you know
yeah poor [ __ ] poor yeah
yeah yeah
but like so i i put it you know i put
tightened it it tightened it i tried it
a second time just to see babe don't get
angry this is amazing
yeah it's pretty cool my theory works i
kind of want you guys to make it i know
we should actually show brian yeah dude
the thing is is this it's easy to make
it the first night
and i hid mine during the day
my brother just leaves it out i go what
if mom walks up there no i hit it like
on the side of the bed and oh you did
hide yeah
i thought like you left it out no way no
oh yeah yeah no so you guys each have
your little canned [ __ ]
and then who tries it first you or him
we didn't do it's in the room same room
i know but like what are you like
brother let's do it together
at what point did you guys convene and
then say hey like did it work for you
the next morning or the next day the
next day
dude we said good morning yeah no you
say you you don't talk about it
right when you wake up yeah no no no no
you have coffee yeah lately
later like a couple hours later
awkwardly i turned to him i go did you
do it mm-hmm because yeah it works so
good bob mm-hmm it got mine busted open
so yeah well this is my trick is i don't
know if you
try i don't know
well it is like my um my style was um i
didn't use
um i didn't use lotion vaseline
so i took vaseline you didn't tell me
about that i didn't no see that worked
that's why you should tell me that i
thought i did did you go dry baby no we
brought jerkins we had like vaseline
yeah we bought like about five or six
different kinds so my question is is
this a one time used pocket [ __ ] or do
you nut inside and how do you clean it
oh you just take the latex glove out and
then discard it oh so you can you can
you can make one it was a 50
glove package yeah we bought a 50 oh
[ __ ] oh yeah
yeah we could have made 50 if we wanted
to yeah yeah if we wanted to yeah yeah
but anyway um we did that while my dad
was downstairs
dying jesus guys you know so it's a
weird way to put it though yeah yeah but
that's the thing i hear that sadness
does cause people to be hypersexual
though yeah you think so
you made a homemade war in your career
i'm like because in my eyes i'm like oh
bobby has everything i don't have
anything
um but here's another thing i want to
say about you have you ever seen his
fingers i have it does he keep picking
please can you can you just give me an
honest assessment of what you see for
him okay
especially the thumbs the thumbs up yeah
they're mutant phones i people um make
fun of me jordan peele makes fun of me
about baron who's there what do they
look like to you wolverines toes
well that's [ __ ] rude
you could have held back on that one
sorry i mean he just called you talented
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i have [ __ ]
up fingers man and what are you gonna do
sometimes when i if i'm in a tv show or
whatever i purposely do this no yeah
i've already got like i'm sitting on the
table i do this to hide my [ __ ]
thumbs wait
when you're about to do a magic trick
that never happens
or i'll just you know what i mean
one time i go put makeup because i did
do fingers uh they show my fingers and i
had i just did a whole makeup thing with
my fingers
what do you mean a makeup thing they put
makeup on my fingers and stuff because
it's a snow buzzer yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
it's like khloe kardashian's revenge
hand
that's not talking about that anymore
all right i feel insecure okay
you were doing you were twiddling your
thumbs and i just my focus just went
straight there i'm sorry and laban was
the first guy to when i when i was using
drugs to give me an intervention he's a
really good dude yeah i love that guy
yeah he's a great guy he's right there
yeah i hadn't seen him in like laban has
a photograph
wait hold up are you going right there
well laban's the first guy he picked me
up from the airport
nobody came down there when i first came
to l.a he was there during the dumpster
days no but don't remember the first
time you visited me and i didn't pick
you up nobody picked you up oh can we
talk about that but nothing happened he
left you stranded at the airport i was
stranded at the airport where was i
i don't know i was in vegas that's when
you live with shama yeah and he had like
[ __ ] 10 cat i got a dude i almost
died like my immune system yeah yeah oh
cause you were allergic yeah but shayman
had a bunch of cats i hated him
so anyway
back to the photo yeah so anyway
yeah laban was there when i first moved
to la when we lived on uh you know in
silver lake echo park yeah area and uh
yeah man he was your best friend yeah i
love him
but uh he did something what do you do
i don't know i think one
one night i stuck a
uh
it had to do with your butt hole in his
snickers bar
get directly into it
dude what it is is this i was gonna
stick to this
sticker you know i was on the street
in your body
and you stuck it in my [ __ ] well you
willingly because you wanted him to i
don't know we did yeah wow guys but the
thing is i didn't know i didn't know
what it would do
was there and um
when he took the picture my face was so
you were inserting it like by the bubble
yeah and laban took a picture of it yeah
so i'm like this like this
and he uh bob had a big birthday party
at the spaghetti factory i used to have
okay so mine was that there used to be a
smell yeah there's a spaghetti factory
on sunset boulevard and i used to do my
birthday parties there and they used to
be the best now i'm not kidding you
i mean you know mencia paulie shore
you know my tv people and then all the
comics and skaters and it was a dinner
and and so my brother and i were sitting
there at this woman with the 60 70
people there and
dude your manager management was there
yeah abby was there yeah abby was blamed
for everyone everywhere my agent
everything and so what laban did he made
multiple copies xerox copies of my face
of my face
with the snickers bar in his butthole
and then you can see bob's nut sack and
i was like this he's sticking it in his
butthole and uh
he passed it around
um no it's not it was basically
everyone that came to the party
oh
welcome to the welcome to the party
right which i didn't it's like a grab
bag
then what
well it ruined i don't know if you
remember i was close to dating someone
named rose
yeah and like yeah and she afterwards
she she came up to me and what'd she say
why did you do it
why did she wait why didn't she looking
like you killed a person why did you do
it why did you do it steve why and then
she was like shaking oh my god
i've i loved him he was my friend yeah
we were at a birthday party together
yeah at spaghetti factory looking at a
picture of a snicker bar up your
brother's ass
oh my god we just talked about that
about that no one has proof no one can
find it
would we like to do a lobotomy and check
it out
see now that was real because he was
there if he could vouch for eric
stonestreet yeah oh my god my brother
was on he talked about that
yeah
it was really up his butt then yeah yeah
about this far
oh so there was like a god wow
ah
yeah labeon had done that yeah see
annabelle what a random thing to look at
the spaghetti factory i know
by the way
you look pale you said hi hi
i um
i i think i lost the ability to clinch
your clinch or what
the [ __ ] so you just
like to push or to cinch to to cut it
you always have to cut the tips you
don't it just has to all of it come out
like carrots you know you click you cut
you know kegel like a yeah but i can't
clinch so it's like when i do clinch
it makes a cake
thing what okay
cake batter yeah like i try to clinch it
and it doesn't clinch all the way
so that it just goes like against i
don't know against your butt cheeks yeah
is it a hard wipe
yeah the wipes are gnarly bobby there's
one thing that's on my mind right now i
want to say yeah and you were gone for a
minute one minute yeah and in that time
you're saying you went in the bathroom
pull down your pants [ __ ] this cake [ __ ]
on your butt cheeks wiped your ass wipe
this messy cake [ __ ] off washed your
hands yeah i just went back in here yeah
in a minute that's very fast yeah you
don't take well i mean first of all i
want to say this is that
it wasn't a full it wasn't a full
session
okay it was like a uh rehearsal quick
adr
it was a quick little rehearsal
just to get that you know get get it out
yeah and um
i clinched it real quick i don't think i
wiped entirely fully but i'm gonna do
that when we're done here will you have
sex with her if she's sick
yeah
okay yeah i think he'd have sex with a
vacuum cleaner do you have sex every day
it's been a while yeah it's been a while
and it's been a while you're touching us
yeah
i think what it is is this
is
the